[Música]
Daniel Ortega negó que la excarcelación
y posterior destierro de más de 200
prisioneros políticos hacia Estados
Unidos se llevará a cabo a cambio de que
se levantaran las sanciones en contra de
su gobierno el régimen sandinista
también despojó a los opositores de su
nacionalidad nicaragüense
de acuerdo con la fundación insight
crime sigue siendo preocupante los
índices de violencia en América Latina
siendo el Caribe la zona donde se
registró un fuerte aumento de homicidios
durante 2022 territorios insulares como
las Islas turcas jamaica y Santa Lucía
registran las tasas más altas
miles de peruanos volvieron a
movilizarse en varias ciudades del país
en contra de la presidenta Dina boluarte
los manifestantes también rindieron
homenaje a las víctimas mortales que han
dejado las protestas que iniciaron en
rechazo a la destitución de Pedro
Castillo
Hola Bienvenidos a las noticias del
continente americano en las 24 los
saluda Andrés Meza Muñoz empezamos en
Nicaragua 222 presos políticos fueron
desterrados Estados Unidos y les
quitarán incluso la ciudadanía
nicaragüense entre los expulsados hay
candidatos opositores y Defensores de
Derechos Humanos Daniel Ortega aseguró
que las excarcelaciones no fueron
negociadas con Estados Unidos a cambio
de que se levantaran las sanciones en su
contra
una amarga Liberación seguida del
destierro la justicia nicaragüense
escarceló sin previo aviso a 222 presos
políticos opositores críticos disidentes
sandinistas Defensores de derechos
humanos y estudiantes detenidos por
supuestamente desafiar al régimen
autoritario de Daniel Ortega los
deportados fueron declarados traidores a
la patria y sancionados por diferentes
delitos graves e inhabilitados de forma
perpetua para ejercer la función pública
En nombre del Servicio del Estado de
Nicaragua así como ejercer cargos de
elección popular entonces encarcelados
deportados a Estados Unidos desde la
prisión de la modelo se enteraron a las
puertas de subir al avión de su
expulsión siendo también despojados de
sus derechos Como ciudadanos
nicaragüenses en el país norteamericano
familiares y amigos esperaban su llegada
muy aferrada a la esperanza de que un
día va a ser libre y eso cualquiera con
una dictadura podría agachar la y ella
siempre se mantuvo muy positiva y muy
fuerte Washington elogió la liberación y
sostuvo que fue una decisión unilateral
del régimen de Ortega algo que reiteró
el mismo mandatario nicaragüense cuando
llegaron llegaron a preguntar que
qué interés teníamos nosotros ninguno
que se lo llevan eso es
todo o sea no se trataba de negociar
aquí no ha habido ninguna negociación
esto debe quedar claro
porque la soberanía del país
la dignidad de la patria
no se negocia mientras que la
organización de los Estados Americanos
exigió a Nicaragua restituir los
derechos de los presos políticos en
Nicaragua todavía hay personas
encarceladas y torturadas por pensar
diferente todavía hay personas que viven
a diario con el temor de ser detenidas
juzgadas Y sentenciadas sin ninguna
garantía legal ni procesal según el
mecanismo de presas y presos políticos
de Nicaragua un observatorio civil
todavía quedan 38 presos políticos en
las cárceles del país centroamericano
las tasas de homicidio en América Latina
y el Caribe durante 2022 huyeron siendo
muy altas según el reporte de insight
crime el organismo muestra que la
producción de cocaína alcanzó nuevos
récords lo que impactó particularmente
los asesinatos en Ecuador donde subieron
un 80%
América Latina y el Caribe fue la región
con más homicidios del mundo otra vez en
2022 para inside crime el narcotráfico
la fragmentación de grupos criminales y
el tráfico ilegal de armas están entre
las principales causas El Caribe es una
zona crítica las Islas turcas y caicos
tienen una tasa de 77,6 homicidios por
cada 100.000 habitantes con un aumento
de más del doble de asesinatos respecto
a 2021 esto debido al terror sembrado
por bandas jamaiquinas le sigue
precisamente Jamaica con una tasa de
homicidios de 52,9 por cada 100.000
habitantes por primera vez en tres años
no registra la tasa más alta del mundo
Aunque sus números siguen siendo
alarmantes sobre todo por el tráfico de
armas preocupa también la situación en
Haití aunque no hay registros oficiales
la ONU señala Un aumento de las muertes
en un 35,2% con las pandillas
controlando la capital Puerto Príncipe
la situación en el Continente también es
preocupante con Venezuela en cabeza con
40 homicidios por 100.000 habitantes
esto significa 26 muertes al día en un
país que tiene múltiples
microestructuras callejeras Honduras que
redujo en cerca de un 13% los asesinatos
respecto a 2021 sigue siendo el más
mortal de Centroamérica y Colombia
registra altas tasas de homicidios en
las regiones con presencia de conflicto
armado algo contra lo que el presidente
Gustavo Petro Busca terminar con su
proyecto de paz total
el informe de insight crime destaca
especialmente dos países Ecuador que
aumentó un 82% la tasa de homicidios en
un crecimiento ligado a los niveles
históricos de cocaína que ingresaron al
país desde Colombia Mientras que el
Salvador Tuvo una drástica reducción por
la guerra contra las pandillas del
presidente nayib bukele que sin embargo
ha ido de la mano de múltiples denuncias
de violación a los Derechos Humanos
una serie de protestas recorrieron
diversas ciudades de Perú en juliaca
recorrieron a las recordaron a las
una serie de protestas recorrieron
diversas ciudades de Perú en juliaca
recordaron a las 18 víctimas que hace un
mes perdieron la vida durante una
manifestación mientras que en Lima la
confederación general de trabajadores
pedía un paro general para presionar a
la salida de Dina boluarte
adelanto de elecciones renuncia de Dina
boluarte esas siguen siendo las
exigencias de los manifestantes que este
jueves han vuelto a recorrer las calles
de las principales ciudades de Perú
renuncia de una vez y si estoy acá es
porque estoy haciendo por una lucha
justa por qué estoy luchando por el
futuro de acá de mi pequeñita de mi hija
Y ahorita la ahorita lo único que yo
pediría que que renuncie para que todo
se calme para que todo pase ya de una
vez en juliaca al sur del país una
vigilia recordó a las 18 personas que a
su mes perdieron la vida en violentas
protestas cuando los manifestantes que
intentaban tomar el aeropuerto local
Fueron repelidos por la policía
pedimos justicia la comisión
internacional de Derechos Humanos tiene
conocimiento de todo esto y ellos tienen
que dar un pronunciamiento a la
población
cerca de 60 personas han perdido la vida
desde que comenzaron las protestas el
miércoles la respuesta de la Comisión
Interamericana de Derechos Humanos ha
sido otorgar medidas cautelares a la
fiscal que ha llevado a cabo las
investigaciones contra el destituido
presidente Pedro Castillo Patricia
Benavides Por considerar que corre
peligro en medio de la crisis
institucional en Lima la policía
desplegó Diez mil efectivos para hacer
frente a la convocatoria de protestas
por parte de la central Obrera más
grande del país mientras un grupo de
eurodiputados de izquierda pedía la
Unión Europea sumarse a los esfuerzos
por restituir la paz en Perú queremos
que es necesario que la comunidad
internacional tome carta en el asunto no
mire controlado ante una un atropello
como el que está sufriendo el pueblo el
pueblo peruano la perspectiva de una
salida institucional luce bloqueada al
igual que la convocatoria a un nuevo
debate parlamentario sobre el adelanto
de elecciones
y empezaron en Chile los toques de queda
impuestos por el gobierno en las zonas
afectadas por los incendios forestales
varios de los cuales todavía continúan
activos ahora las autoridades se
concentran y en la recuperación de las
zonas afectadas y en la ayuda para las
familias damnificadas desde Santa Juana
nuestra enviada especial Patricia Luna
nos envió el siguiente reporte
jornada marcada por la humedad que ha
favorecido el combate de los 323
incendios declarados en esta jornada la
mayoría de ellos controlados pero 90
todavía muy activos y también jornada en
la que entra en vigor el toque de queda
declarado por el gobierno en 28 comunas
o poblados entre ellos la comuna de
Santa Juana cerca de la cual nos
encontramos en tres regiones del país la
región del biobío en la que nos
encontramos la región de la araucanía y
la región del ñuble todas ellas bajo
estado de catástrofe el toque de queda
declarado por el gobierno tiene la
misión de garantizar la seguridad de
aquellas personas que no quieren
alejarse de las pocas pertenencias que
todavía tienen pie cerca de las zonas de
incendio ante el temor de que estas sean
arrebatadas por terceros el gobierno
también comienza a anunciar medidas
encaminadas a la reconstrucción
entregará ayudas económicas que
oscilarán entre los 1500 y los 750
dólares en función de la afectación lo
hará de forma inmediata en las próximas
semanas y también entregará viviendas de
alta calidad viviendas temporales
aquellas personas que hayan perdido su
hogar más de 1.200 viviendas han sido
completamente destruidas y arrasadas por
el fuego en estos incendios entre ellas
20 establecimientos escolares el saldo
que dejan también estos incendios son
más de dos decenas de personas
fallecidas y más de 2.000 heridos pero
también ha afectado mucho a las formas
de vida a la forma de ganarse de la vida
en una en una área del país
eminentemente agrícola Ganadera y
también forestal por eso entre las
medidas del gobierno también se trata de
fomentar la empleabilidad
hasta aquí es informativo Gracias por
acompañarnos
[Música]